then do you masturbate masturbation yes
how is it different when you're married
versus when you're single you make
videos about this all the time
what's your jerking off history like
well you know as a teenager I
experimented did it a lot I kind of did
it so much that as a child my mom told
me to stop she was like don't do that so
much because your vagina's gonna fall
off if you do it too much your vagina
fall off if you masturbate too much no
cuz I still got that nice checks out
checks oh yeah when is the last time
that you masturbated 1 2 3
last night I can't remember when your
wife leaves to go somewhere is your
first thought immediate no I'm a
roommate it's so like the second my
roommate is out the door with my pants
are off but I feel like with marriage
you have someone there to help you
through those times if you want to
masturbate and your partner's like you
know he doesn't want to have sex then
sometimes you know it's a group activity
there are all kinds of ways macerate it
doesn't have to just be with your hand
or with a toy like do some weird
googling kids just make sure to set your
browser private number of times in a
week that you masturbate 1 2 3
0.5 porn oh yeah how'd that changed
since you've been married sometimes we
watched porn together you know I have to
watch porn because I don't have anyone
to imagine really single person's
masturbation kit looks a little
something like this a vibrator of some
sort my cell phone cuz gotta watch porn
son and me sometimes all you need is
your old right
- masturbate do it and if you have a
partner talk about it with them or do it
together if you're masturbating right
now we we get it we I don't blame you
like oh yeah
[Music]